if you've seen Logan in the movie
theater you might have got to see the
secret Deadpool - teaser which plays
just before the main movie it's a fun
little short that gives us some nice
Easter eggs for the Merc with the mouth
upcoming sequel the scene isn't part of
the main Logan movie so I won't be
discussing Logan spoilers in this video
we're obviously there are spoilers for
the Deadpool teaser and speculation
about Deadpool - if you prefer you can
check out my spoiler free review of
Logan here and come back and watch this
video after you've seen the teaser the
scene begins with Ryan Reynolds as Wade
Wilson walking past an alley where an
old man is being held up at gunpoint he
pulls down his hoodie shakes his head
and says not on my watch [ __ ]
and runs to a phone booth opposite a
movie theater which just happens to be
playing Logan after he gets into the
phone booth John Williams's Superman
score starts up and he begins to change
out of his regular clothes into a
Deadpool costume
cries and police were helped come from
the man being mugged as Wade struggled
hilariously to get into a suit all the
while the epic Superman theme is playing
and the chiefly amusing moment where
Ryan Reynolds practices bare bust up
against the phone booth glass but just
as Wade's almost finished as a loud
gunshot followed by silence
Deadpool finishes getting dressed as
quick as he can exits the booth and run
slow-mo across the street to the rising
Superman theme when he reaches the guy
who's been shot the scene cuts out and
Deadpool jokes about spending way too
long in the phone booth Deadpool and
decide to lie down and rest his head on
the dead guy and start eating a tub of
the man's ice cream Deadpool is his
usual meta wisecracking self in this
teaser making jokes about how weird it
is that there's a phone booth on the
street how he should have used his cell
phone to ring 9-1-1 and how other
superheroes get changed so quickly
he also pokes fun at Logan who he says
probably would have saved the dead guy
as he doesn't have to change into
anything at his costume sister tank top
and jeans and I think eats the ice cream
he says our brain freeze a possible
little nod to x-men apocalypse is
deleted brain freeze scene where
Nightcrawler thinks he's frozen his
brain after drinking a nice drink the
words Deadpool coming not soon enough
then appear on screen followed by a
scrolling screen of text in which we get
a Deadpool style commentary on Ernest
Hemingway's Pulitzer prize-winning
novels the Old Man and the sea complete
with references to the fresh prince and
Marilyn Monroe so that was the scene now
let's jump back to some Easter Egg snuck
in around the phone
buthe first up is some graffiti which
reads Nathan summers coming soon
scrawled on the phone booth this is a
big piece to cable who we know is in
Deadpool too and perhaps the hint that
we'll have a casting announcement soon
recent news claims that David Harbor who
played chief Jim hopper in stranger
things to screen tested for the role
alongside Reynolds Michael Shannon was
apparently also in the running but
dropped out because of scheduling issues
there's also speculation that cable
might be played by Pierce Brosnan after
Ryan Reynolds shared a photo of himself
with Brosnan and Hugh Jackman earlier
this year for anyone who doesn't know
cable assassin of Cyclops and Jean Grey
clone Madeleine Pryor and he's a
time-traveling mutant cyborg for the
cybernetic eye Bionic arms superhuman
strength and telepathic and telekinetic
powers in the comics cable also
established the x-force basically an
offshoot of the x-men so he could be
tied in with that movie too once it gets
off the ground by the way there's also
some graffiti which reads ray on the
movie theater behind the phone booth
probably a little nod to Reynolds
himself and when Deadpool emerges from
the phone booth you can also spot some
Firefly posters although Reynolds won in
a 2008 movie called fireflies in the
garden it's much more likely a reference
to Morena Baccarin who starred in
Firefly and played Vanessa in Deadpool
say guys what do you think of the
Deadpool short and how hype do you for
Deadpool - and who do you think should
be cast as cable I'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below also
check out my latest x-men video with the
23 coolest Easter eggs and x-men
connections in Logan plus I'm giving
away some awesome logo merchandise on
that video if you enjoyed the associate
those like and subscribe buttons
plus you can't Apple click here for
other videos you might like thanks for
watching and see you next time you'd be
going movie lovers